hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video nach einer ewigkeit mal
wieder hier einfach in meinem zimmer vor
dem pc ich mache nämlich heute eine neue
action video das liegt daran dass ich
den höllen stress habe mit der gamescom
und so weiter und so fort ich habe
eigentlich sachen gekauft für neues
video was ich mir sebastian und luca und
mit jana und sonstwie aufnehmen könnte
aber ich habe gerade einfach mal ein
bisschen zeit und möchte wirklich gerne
video für euch machen einfach weil ihr
auch so media aktiv sei gerade auf
meinem kanal und ich das übertrieben
feier deshalb mache ich heute ein wie
action video bitte steinig mich nicht
kommt ja nicht allzu häufig vor auf
meinem kanal ich hoffe mal dass wir
durch trotzdem gefallen ist es nämlich
wirklich sehr spicy ich muss sagen ich
glaube natürlich habe ich noch nicht
komplett geschaut versteht sich ja von
selbst aber ich glaube das könnte
richtig richtig krass werden wir gucken
nämlich ein video das ist eine
compilation bahn erwachsenen die sich
schlimmer als kinder verhalten lässt
okay in diese richtung geht das heute
ganz einfach irgendwelche leute die sich
übertrieben archiv benehmen und dass
auch der hintergrund warum ich dieses
video machte ich möchte nämlich meine
vorbildfunktion wahrnehmen und zeigen
das ist nicht in ordnung und so habt ihr
euch bitte nicht zu verhalten so gebt
euch mal wie es einfach meint das kind
richtig gemein ich glaube so was gibt es
richtig häufig baseball spielen und so
dass man den kindern irgendwie was
schenken und alle einfach an was geht
jetzt wo gott ich glaube ich weiß was
das ist
ich glaube ich weiß was es ist es gibt
in amerika so was das heißt black friday
und das ist ein tag an dem es einfach
alles übertrieben reduziert also ein tag
im jahr an dem irgendwie alle komplett
verrückt spielen und sagen zb bei uns
kostet heute ein iphone statt 800 euro
400 euro und deshalb ist jeder verrückte
an diesem tag in den geschäften und kauf
teilt das was er sich das ganze jahr
über nicht leisten konnte weil es halt
ein bisschen günstiger ist teilweise
sind halt irgendwie nicht 50 prozent
sondern so 10
und jedes jahr wenn dieser black
freighter ist sieht man auf twitter so
videos von leuten die da irgendwie
kämpfen und keine ahnung und die scheiße
machen einfach irgendwie gegeneinander
ringen oder so was irgendwie eine
nintendo switch oder so ein zeug und das
ist übertrieben es sind das immer
anzusehen weil das ist so pure dummheit
und ich weiß nicht also ich bin
eigentlich ganz froh dass so was in
deutschland nicht gibt es gibt
vereinzelt aber irgendwie vor allem
online halt und online ist das ja noch
okay weil dann bist du halt irgendwie
superschnelle auf deiner seite aber du
kollidiert nicht mit anderen leuten die
auch das zeug günstig haben wollen
ein bisschen was sagen sie redet er mit
dem kinder
[Musik]
und erwachsene typ den kleinen jungen
wobei meine ich muss sagen an dieser
stelle ist eigentlich respektabel
anscheinend läuft er davor bei hat keine
nähere verbindung und hört jemand jemand
anderes beleidigen sagt er macht das
nicht das nicht okay so hat er sich halt
vertan und so weit ist das ja eigentlich
auch schon in ordnung wenn auch so der
ton in dem er mit einem kind spricht er
sagt irgendwie moment der sagt und
bietet pcs bippus iss sind drei
beleidigungen geprägt soll nicht er soll
nicht ausfallen werden und ja ich
benutze es drei beleidigung
[Musik]
weiter geht's in die kamera wie auch
immer film wahrscheinlich ein anderes
gehen
finger kriege range trading
er sagte wegen junge schlagen 14 jahre
alten jungen sap uk okay das ist richtig
lächerlich erscheinen wir die gleiche
geschichte oder der ball heute einfach
langweilig der kämpft der kämpft alter
der kämpft krass ja gut aber hier so im
fan-chat und sowas
das mädel hat irgendwie schwer ohne 1
weint auch oder liest oder blut also
blut ja gerade deshalb die scheiße in
amerika wird ja immer verfolgt werden
diesen ball kriegt und du hast ja immer
die kameras optieren jetzt kommt der
nächste harte brocken
hier sind die fingernägel abgebrochen
was ein und entschuldigt sich auch nicht
mal ja aber wie gerade sagen heute das
halt immer eine kamera auf die gott ja
ich glaube davon haben wir genug das
wollen wir uns nicht mehr anschauen
so was geht jetzt ablöst wer glaubt
schon wieder beide kriegen sagt es gibt
genug aber den tisch
so habe ich dann besucht von sebastian
bekommen überraschung in der aufnahme
sowas passiert
okay das war ein moment ok ok bevor wir
uns das anschauen noch einmal ganz kurz
hier
ok ja deshalb korrekt oder ein anderer
typ hier hat irgendwie ein ball selbst
dabei und gibt
denn bei dem kleinen jungen das ist cool
das vorbildlich aber krasse die leute
einfach abgenutzt ist einfach nur ein
ball den irgendwie stahlen starspieler
geschlagen hat so kann ich gar nicht
verstehen irgendwie seitdem ich selbst
auch so ein bisschen berühmt haben bzw
seitdem hat leute mit mir fotos machen
würde ich auch glaube ich selten nur
noch zuläufen hingehen und sagen hey
porto machen welch reist irgendwie sind
die coolsten momente nicht die wo man
halt irgendwie gemeinsam in eine handy
kamera lächelt sondern wo man irgendwie
keine ahnung sich austauscht oder wenn
es ein musiker wäre dann würde ich mir
irgendwie so einem krieg feier deine
musik und du bist ein cooler typ oder so
aber so ein foto machen würde ich glaube
ich gar nicht weil mein ich habe ja die
erinnerung eine anregung für euch okay
was war jetzt bitte da gerade los alter
das weit übertrieben
als optimum springt ein bisschen zurück
gibt ihr mal wieder schwung holt what
the [ __ ] vorlegen wie der typ jetzt hier
runter fliegt das ja noch viel krasser
und wahnsinn aber kraft safe gebt euch
mal ich bin jetzt mal in slow motion
einen wie er sich wieder gefangen hat
dem ok der typ hat auf jeden fall die
muss ich glaube der skate irgendwo wo er
nicht gelten soll und der rasse aus
es ist kein park ihre halter was für ein
idiot mega asozial also dass es sieht
vor allem im außenamt öffentlichen platz
und irgendwie wenn privatgelände wäre
okay ist der komplett gestört der typ
ist anscheinend hingegangen hat gesagt
ey was los warum machst du das mit den
kindern und der was war das denn gerade
für eingriffe die irgendein hals gepackt
und gewürgt
es gibt echt leute der komplett gestört
die leute da hinten warum machen die
nichts mit sehen was ist das denn für so
was mache ich so sauer
alter schwede
vielleicht ist man in so einem fall ist
das einzige was du machen kannst die
projekte
ich finde es auch so schlimm generell
ist das allerschlimmste wenn leute
irgendwie physisch werden sagen wir mal
du bist bei einer party und irgendwie
idiot kommt hat einen schlechten tag und
will ich mit dem boxen so dass das
stressigste auf der ganzen welt ich
finde technik setzen da ist das mich
hast du es immer wenn sich irgendwie so
eine spannung aufbaut so bin ich direkt
so fange ich hasse das kasse das war ich
hasse auch diesen typen video ja ohne
spaß erst dessen sowie das geld skaten
ist halt auch so eine sache ist
übertrieben laut und so und hier ist
gerade sind ja irgendwie in der stadt
und sonstwie und da nervt fakten sich
glaube ich richtig viele drüber okay
denn luther hinten kommt jetzt ein was
macht hat den man sieht es leider nicht
der nimmt ein skateboard läufers ist
kaputt gemacht
wie sieht er dennoch auch wenn ihr auf
jeden fall nein als auch mit als ob er
wollte seine waffe ziehen einfach ich
glaube ist und bis so eine amerikanische
sache so wenn eine waffe trägt kann
irgendwie scheiße erlauben weil die
leute denken okay besser auf sonst
knallt der abschluss einfach zu
studieren ok davon hatten wir jetzt auch
genug so dass thomas okay leute das
war's dann auch hoffe es hat euch
gefallen also es ist einerseits
interessant sich sowas anzugucken weil
man kann eigentlich auch nicht wegducken
wenn scheiße passiert aber pocher sind
das [ __ ] also das sind teilweise echt
solche arschlöcher gewesen haben
allerschlimmsten fall nicht nur typen im
skatepark lasst mir gerne mal in den
kommentaren eure meinung da wenn ihr am
grässlichsten fandet lebt das ganze also
negativbeispiel und falls ihr jemals in
so einer situation seit die netten leute
und nicht die leute die ja so kacke
drauf sind dann will ich sagen sehen uns
beim nächsten mal
ich hoffe ihr könnt mir verzeihen dass
dies ein reaction video war bis zum
nächsten mal